I think it's always been said that if
that the path is a razor's edge
you know that you can fall too far to
one side or the other and the the trick
is to know what you're do getting into
so that you make your choices with open
eyes I have contacted you know these
states of being which are like siren
songs you just say you know my god this
is so impelling that I want to always be
like this I don't and some of them are
Titanic like for instance one of the odd
things in the Amazon when you take
mushrooms but at first I thought was
delightful and then I actually came to
see it is actually a weird kind of
danger so that it always made me a
little uncomfortable is you're sitting
stoned on mushrooms and this idea gets
hold about how you had previously
misperceived the jungle and actually the
jungle is the natural home of man and
the jungle is the mother and you begin
to get a picture in your head of a way
you could be that would fulfill you but
not be human it would be life in the
canopies it would be the life of a
psychedelic super ape you know if the
evolutionary thing had turned another
way and we had developed philosophy the
way we developed science then we would
move in troops through the trees and
contemplation of the absolute outside of
history history could never need never
have happened and you know you're just
thinking away on this ok yeah it sounds
pretty good
mm-hmm and what are the conclusions to
be drawn and they are you know that you
you are choosing to sit here doing this
you're choosing to play botanist death
no pharmacologist American citizen
father lover you're choosing to do all
this it's ok to choose to do it but you
are choosing to do it it is not a fate
you aren't set into it you could just
right now just
quietly and walk toward the green and
keep moving now what would happen to you
if you did that
orthodoxy says night would fall the the
muskers would gather and you would die
within hours if not days of madness
induced by insect bites if not being
chewed on by some large animal but the
state says no it says you know as you're
leaving behind your humaneness you're
leaving behind all these assumptions you
know it doesn't work like that you know
that the cutting edge of being is will
and it is going to be the way you will
it to be and I've never tested the limit
of this thing but I have seen briefly
people do things where they willed it
the way it was to be and it bordered you
know on the uncanny and this is what the
the suit the feats of super balancing
that are in Carlos Castenada tricks on
waterfalls and that kind of thing this
is where you say you know what I can do
I can do almost anything I want to do
and then proceeded to go out on the
razor's edge and perform these things
and they challenge you know the
ontological definition of humaneness the
thing that we were investigating when we
went to the Amazon challenges the
ontological definition of humanists what
we were looking for we had heard reports
that in very off the river situations in
these very uh nicole traded tribes that
people shaman taking ayahuasca vomited
an exotic material that was some somehow
it was like a part of their body
it was a regurgitate able magical organ
of some sort that they then looked into
this stuff and could see
it was their means of divining it was
how they found lost objects how they saw
the future how they performed all their
magic was by means of a psycho physical
fluid generated inside their own body
well this is either you know big news or
absolute madness there's very little
room to maneuver with a notion like that
but then you know you you get out there
in the jungle and it all begins to
dissolve because language binds us the
way atomic forces bind metallic atoms in
a matrix we all believe the same thing
because there are thousands and
thousands of us here all packed closely
together all more or less believing the
same thing if you go off into isolation
you're like you're like an electron
moving out of a metallic matrix suddenly
you're no longer bound by the rules that
govern the mass phenomena of metallic
atoms suddenly you're subject to a new
set of laws and you discover reality is
very malleable and and can change right
in front of you and then with the
addition of psychedelics you discover
you know that language is the leading
edge and that it can be projected into
the world then the trick is to learn you
know how to do this
without becoming unbalanced how to do it
without hurting other people and finally
how to do it and actually help people
but it's a strange notion and it's been
tugging at the human experience probably
since before history probably for the
past twenty or thirty thousand years
there has been you know this in the
peripheral vision of the collectivity of
the species the awareness that mind is a
very funny thing and that put through
the mill with psychedelic drugs very
interesting thing
and happen the the user of the
psychedelic plants he lives in his world
has much greater reality for him than
the world of modern physics has for the
people who practice modern physics
because it's an experiential world and
and yet we dismiss it entirely you know
as a kind of psychologism a kind of
delusion but it's because we are so
certain that language secures the ground
of being
[Music]